Hey everyone! Sometimes we need to know ...
if the move that we want to make is worthwhile.
While we don't have a time machine to peer into the ...
future, we can use experiments to ...
help us better understand if some initial change has the ...
impact that we are looking for.
Why do we care?
We are in the business of, well,
being in business and making the right decisions ...
can improve our outcomes.
This is where having a well-designed experiment ...
really ups the ante by allowing us to make causal ...
inferences into business policy,
changes, et cetera.
We gain functional knowledge that reduces ...
uncertainty. This,
then leads to information that we may use later.
A simple question. We know,
or will know, that if we know the price ...
elasticity of demand for a particular product we can ...
raise or lower price to increase revenue.
But our goal may not always be to raise revenue.
Perhaps, you're trying to align with ...
another organizational goal of maximizing profits,
in which case continually increasing revenue has the ...
downfall of added costs.
What to do? Simply conduct a randomized ...
experiment to find out. This is where the tricky part ...
comes in. You have to be able to set up ...
the experiment so randomization of consumers ...
are not related in any systematic way.
Suppose you offer a voucher to the first 100 people who ...
enter your store on Tuesday. Why Tuesday?
Why not Tuesday?
What will we notice? That there are 100 motivated ...
people looking to get the voucher.
This is not randomization. Perhaps,
you have a machine that distributes vouchers using a ...
random number generator. The first person who gets a ...
voucher is customer number 3,
then next person is customer number 5,
then the next is customer number 9.
With this method, we can see if the vouchers ...
have any effect on shopping. This also lets us potentially ...
avoid selection bias.With our first proposed method of ...
giving out the vouchers to the first 100 people we create an ...
incentive for the highly motivated to be at the store ...
first. This distorts the true effect of ...
the treatment of our experiment, or goal.
Here we have our store with an end cap display that is ...
30%. We did this because an ...
eager young assistant manager promised that we ...
could increase sales of the items nearby as well.
If this endcap is not displayed in an ad and only customers ...
who enter the store know about it,
then we have added some degree of randomness to the ...
assistant manager's assertion.
However, if it is made known ...
beforehand, then we may find ...
self-selection arising and distorting the true effect as ...
customers may enter with the sole intent of getting a ...
product from the discount bin.
Other issues arise as well when we are creating ...
experiments. The first is leakages.
Let's suppose we are conducting an experiment on ...
price discounts at a local grocery store.
This will be our treatment group.
To see if these discounts work we need to compare ...
sales with another grocery store that isn't running the ...
price discounts. The issue we face is that our ...
control store may be in too close of proximity and some ...
customers visit that store for the same goods for whatever reason.
If we worry about leakages, then we will want to choose a ...
store further away.
Another issue that arises is representativeness.
Our grocery store want to make sure that their sales ...
can be closely tied to an area,
so they choose another local store (perhaps owned by the ...
same company) to use as a control group.
But as we just learned this may cause leakages.
In the end, we are faced with a trade-off.
Back to our endcap display. We now have another ...
endcap that looks very close to the discounted one.
We've also lowered the discount to 10%.
We satisfied the representativeness problem ...
by using another endcap as a control that is very close to ...
the discounted one.
But we may have introduced a leakage problem as the ...
10% may not be enough to ...
incentivize customers to purchase from the endcap ...
and surrounding items. Again,
we are faced with a trade-off, and our estimates may not be unbiased.
What if we can't generate a randomized experiment?
Sometimes, we have to rely on historical ...
data and data that we can collect after we make a ...
change. When this is our approach we ...
can use the difference-in-difference method.
This method does allow us to find the effect of an ...
experiment through treatment and control groups.
But we also have to keep in mind that our treatment is not ...
random and we can't control for confounders or a variable ...
that effects the dependent and independent variables at ...
the same time. For example,
we want to know the outcome of sales of turkey,
which is our dependent variable,
when we lower the price of turkey,
which is our independent variable.
If we begin this experiment near Thanksgiving,
then we may learn that historically prices fall during ...
Thanksgiving and that sales increase during ...
Thanksgiving, so we cannot determine the ...
true causal relationship without controlling for a holiday.
Lastly, we have selection bias again.
This, again,
distorts our true effect. With these assumptions,
we can use difference-in-difference to ...
estimate the effect of a change.
To do this, we use this equation,
which says the outcome effect is equal to the ...
difference of the treatment group post change and ...
treatment group pre-change minus the difference of the ...
control group post-change and control group ...
pre-change. Let's see how this works.
We have a scenario given to us where a grocery store is ...
implementing a new advertising campaign and ...
they want to know how well this campaign worked.
They have data going back 12 months and forward 12 ...
months. They compare their sales to ...
similar stores in the region.
We find that the store earned $120,000 in sales ...
post-campaign and $100,000 pre-campaign.
Similar stores earned $115,000 post-campaign and ...
$110,000 pre-campaign.
To estimate the effect, let's first recall the outcome ...
effect of the difference-in-difference estimator
Next, let's plug our pre and post ...
numbers into their corresponding spots.
Solving down and we get.
$15,000 as the total effect to include our time-varying and ...
constant factors. This tells us we could expect ...
a $5,000 change already with no ad campaign.
And by having the ad campaign we added an ...
additional $10,000 in sales.
We'll conclude by placing the previous numbers in a table.
This table sorts out the control and treatment groups ...
sales as well as adding in two new columns.
The factors constant over time measures the change ...
from the treatment group. That is,
we are looking at how the group changes by itself.
Subtracting the post treatment and pre-treatment ...
yields $20,000.
And the time-varying factors measures the control group.
This allows us to see what would have happened had ...
nothing else taken place over time.
Subtracting the post control and pre-control yields $5,000.
We take the difference of these two measures to get $15,000.
Alright, that's it.
Hope you've enjoyed it and we'll catch you in the next one.